Hey, there, America. Can we just get this election over with already? We've had enough excitement, right? More than enough plot twists. The president getting coronavirus, Ruth Bader Ginsburg dying, that whole first debate, the alleged contents of Hunter Biden's hard drive-- which are either totally unconvincing or deeply, urgently important, depending on your point of view.
嘿，美国。我们能快点结束这场选举吗？我们经历的刺激已经够多了，对吧？情节反转也已经足够多了。总统感染了冠状病毒，露丝·巴德·金斯伯格去世，那场首场辩论，还有亨特·拜登硬盘里的所谓内容——根据你的观点，这些内容要么完全令人难以信服，要么极其重要且紧迫。
We finally got to see the president's tax records after all these years. That barely seemed to make a dent in anything. Militia plotted to kidnap the governor of Michigan. And then after that, the president's followers chanted, "Lock her up." The president joking, not joking, told his supporters in North Carolina to go out and try to vote twice. And then after that, the attorney general declared on CNN to Wolf Blitzer that voting twice might actually be legal.
这些年来，我们终于看到了总统的税务记录。但这似乎几乎没有产生任何影响。民兵密谋绑架密歇根州州长。此后，总统的支持者高呼“把她关起来”。总统在北卡罗来纳州告诉他的支持者去试着投两次票，是在开玩笑，还是没开玩笑？之后，司法部长在 CNN 对沃尔夫·布利策宣称，投两次票实际上可能是合法的。
I don't know what the law in that particular state says.
我不知道那个特定州的法律是怎么说的。
You can't vote twice.
你不能投两次票。
Well, I don't know what the law in that particular state says. And when that vote becomes final--
嗯，我不知道那个特定州的法律是怎么说的。当那张选票最终生效时——
Is there any state that says you could vote twice?
有哪个州说你可以投两次票吗？
Well, there's some maybe that you can change your vote up to a particular time. I don't know what the law is, so I'm not going to offer.
嗯，也许有些州你可以更改你的选票，直到某个时间点。我不知道法律是什么，所以我不会提供建议。
Attorney General William Barr looks amazingly relaxed as he says all this. Calm, like nothing's out of the ordinary. Nothing to see here, officer. Watching him, it's hard not to think, is this really happening?
司法部长威廉·巴尔在说这一切时看起来非常放松。很冷静，好像没什么不寻常的。警察同志，这里没什么可看的。看着他，很难不让人想，这真的在发生吗？
I got that same feeling looking at photos of the president's rallies where, even now, he's packing people in. Tons of people with no masks, not following CDC guidelines. He's doing this even after he, his wife, his son, his press secretary, his campaign manager, the chair of the Republican National Committee, White House housekeeping and military staff, members of the vice president's staff, Stephen Miller, Kellyanne Conway, and Hope Hicks all got coronavirus. Even though cases are at an all-time high and on the rise. Looking at the not socially distanced crowds, it's like, is this really happening?
看着总统集会的照片，我也有同样的感觉，即使现在，他仍然挤满了人。成吨的人没有戴口罩，没有遵循疾控中心的指导方针。即使在他本人、他的妻子、他的儿子、他的新闻秘书、他的竞选经理、共和党全国委员会主席、白宫管家和军事人员、副总统的工作人员、斯蒂芬·米勒、凯莉安·康威和霍普·希克斯都感染了冠状病毒之后，他仍然在这样做。即使病例处于历史最高水平且在不断上升。看着那些没有保持社交距离的人群，就像是，这真的在发生吗？
And now, coming up, this coming Tuesday, we're either going to have an election with a clear winner or, apparently, the vote will be contested. A contested election seems so possible because the president keeps saying over and over that he's way ahead in the polls, and those polls that we are always seeing on the news saying that he's way behind, those are fake. And so if he loses, he says, there's only one possible explanation.
现在，即将到来的下周二，我们要么会迎来一场有明确获胜者的选举，要么显然，投票结果将被质疑。一场有争议的选举似乎很有可能，因为总统反复说他在民调中遥遥领先，而我们在新闻中经常看到那些说他远远落后的民调是假的。所以如果他输了，他说，只有一个可能的解释。
The only way we can lose, in my opinion, is massive fraud. And that's what's happening, because all over the country, you're seeing it, thousands and thousands of ballots.
在我看来，我们输掉选举的唯一途径就是大规模欺诈。这就是正在发生的事情，因为在全国各地，你都能看到成千上万张选票。
That was Monday in Allentown. Here he is in Oshkosh, Wisconsin.
那是周一在阿伦敦。这是他在威斯康星州奥什科什。
Because the only way we're going to lose this election is if the election is rigged. Remember that. It's the only way we're going to lose this election. And we can't let that happen.
因为我们输掉这次选举的唯一途径就是选举被操纵了。记住这一点。这是我们输掉这次选举的唯一途径。我们不能让这种情况发生。
There is no evidence for any massive fraud like he's talking about. When he talks about mail-in ballots being a problem-- which he does nearly everywhere-- there's no evidence for that either. Lots more Democrats than Republicans are voting with mail-in ballots this year. Here's the president on Sunday in New Hampshire, calling those ballots into question.
没有任何证据表明他所说的那种大规模欺诈存在。当他谈到邮寄选票是个问题时——他几乎在到处都这么说——对此也没有任何证据。今年通过邮寄选票投票的民主党人比共和党人多得多。这是总统周日在新罕布什尔州对这些选票提出质疑。
The other way, they said millions of ballots. We don't know who's sending them. We don't know where they're going. We don't know who's bringing them back. We don't know who's signed them. And it shouldn't be allowed. And the Democrats know it's a hoax. And we shouldn't let it happen.
另一种方式，他们说有数百万张选票。我们不知道是谁寄出的。我们不知道它们要去哪里。我们不知道是谁带回来的。我们不知道是谁签名的。这不应该被允许。民主党人知道这是一个骗局。我们不应该让它发生。
So, this Tuesday, he may fight those ballots. And we might find ourselves in a big, no-holds-barred season finale, contested election, constitutional national meltdown, with both sides arguing over whether to count mail-in ballots and ballots that arrive after November 3. And if that happens, people on both sides will probably take to the streets to protest, and who knows where that might lead?
所以，这个周二，他可能会对这些选票提出抗议。我们可能会发现自己处于一场大型、肆无忌惮的季终集，一场有争议的选举，一场宪法级的国家崩溃，双方都在争论是否要清点邮寄选票和 11 月 3 日之后送达的选票。如果发生这种情况，双方的人可能都会走上街头抗议，谁知道这会导致什么结果呢？
And then, of course, there are the scenarios where the whole thing gets thrown to Congress or the Supreme Court to decide. So many different ways this could play out, where, whichever side loses, red or blue, they'll probably never be able to see the final decision as fair and legitimate. So one half of the country will not accept who the other half puts into office.
然后，当然，还有整个事件被提交给国会或最高法院来裁决的情况。这事可能会以多种方式发展，无论哪一方输了，红色还是蓝色，他们可能永远无法将最终决定视为公平和合法的。所以国家的一半人将不会接受另一半人选出的人进入办公室。
Or maybe that won't happen. Maybe somebody is going to win decisively. That's where we are. Our world is either about to slip into utter chaos or the election will go just fine, and things will be fine. That's the unreality of now. There are so many things right now that make it feel like the ground underneath us is thin as a cracker with molten lava underneath. So many things, it's hard to understand. This is real. This is really happening.
或者也许那不会发生。也许有人会决定性地获胜。这就是我们目前的处境。我们的世界要么即将陷入彻底的混乱，要么选举会进展顺利，一切都会好起来。这就是当下的非现实感。现在有太多的事情让人觉得我们脚下的地面薄得像饼干，下面流淌着熔岩。太多事情了，让人难以理解。这是真实的。这真的在发生。
And today on our program, we have people trying to get their minds around that. I have to say that is so much of the mood as we head into the Simpsons Halloween Special of an election day. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
今天在我们的节目中，我们邀请了试图理解这一切的人。我不得不说，在我们走向辛普森一家选举日万圣节特别节目时，这就是大部分的情绪。来自芝加哥 WBEZ，这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
Act One, Would You Like to Come Up to First Class? So the journalist E. Jean Carroll has been in the news this week when a federal judge ruled that the president can be sued by Caroll. Caroll says that back in the 1990s, Donald Trump raped her in a dressing room in the department store at Bergdorf Goodman. He says she's lying. She's suing him for defamation. She's one of dozens of women who've accused the president of sexual assault and harassment. The president denies all of their allegations.
第一幕，你想上头等舱吗？记者 E·珍·卡罗尔本周上了新闻，一位联邦法官裁定，卡罗尔可以起诉总统。卡罗尔说，在 20 世纪 90 年代，唐纳德·特朗普在波道夫·古德曼百货公司的试衣间里强奸了她。他说她在撒谎。她以诽谤罪起诉他。她是几十位指控总统性侵犯和骚扰的女性之一。总统否认了她们所有的指控。
These stories have been so widely covered and everybody is so used to them. But to Caroll, it felt like, at this point, they were just being ignored, which seemed kind of incredible to her. Our program today is about people feeling like, is this is really happening? And she definitely felt that about this. It killed her that these stories just somehow didn't seem to matter.
这些故事被广泛报道，每个人都已经习惯了。但对卡罗尔来说，感觉就像，在这一点上，它们只是被忽视了，这对她来说似乎有点令人难以置信。我们今天的节目是关于那些感觉像“这真的在发生吗？”的人。她绝对对这一点有这种感觉。这些故事不知何故似乎并不重要，这让她感到非常痛苦。
And this summer, she decided to try to do something about it. She had a bunch of conversations with other women who have accused the president and published them in a series of stories in The Atlantic. And her idea was, most people only have a vague sense of these stories and don't have much of a sense of what these women say actually happened. And by diving into the details of these stories, she'd restore them to human size, in full color.
今年夏天，她决定尝试对此做点什么。她与指控总统的其他女性进行了多次谈话，并将它们发表在《大西洋月刊》的一系列故事中。她的想法是，大多数人对这些故事只有模糊的印象，对这些女性说实际发生了什么并没有太多的了解。通过深入挖掘这些故事的细节，她将把它们恢复到真实的人类尺度，全彩呈现。
She's adapted one of the articles that she wrote for us. It's with one of the president's accusers named Jessica Leeds. A warning about content before we start-- this is a frank conversation about sexual assault. Here's E. Jean Caroll.
她改编了她为我们写的一篇文章。对象是总统的一位指控者杰西卡·利兹。开始前关于内容的警告——这是一场关于性侵犯的坦诚谈话。这是 E·珍·卡罗尔。
Let me set the scene-- midsummer twilight, and Jessica Leeds and I are letting down what's left of our hair. Jessica's in her elegant crib in the Blue Ridge mountains. I'm in my little shack just off the Appalachian Trail. And we're Zooming like two old screech owls, discovering how much we had in common, which includes our love for Mr. Paul Newman, our age, and our height.
让我来设定场景——盛夏黄昏，杰西卡·利兹和我正在放下我们剩余的头发。杰西卡在蓝岭山脉她优雅的住所里。我在阿巴拉契亚小径旁边的小屋里。我们像两只老尖叫猫头鹰一样在 Zoom 上交谈，发现我们有这么多共同点，包括我们对保罗·纽曼先生的热爱，我们的年龄和我们的身高。
How tall are you now?
你现在多高？
Well, I'm 5' 7" now. I was 5' 9" at the-- I've lost two inches.
嗯，我现在 5 英尺 7 英寸。我曾经是 5 英尺 9 英寸——我瘦了 2 英寸。
Me, too. I've lost two inches.
我也是。我瘦了 2 英寸。
I don't know where they've gone, but I've lost them. I love being tall. When I was working, I was always so thankful--
我不知道它们去哪了，但我确实瘦了。我喜欢个子高。当我工作时，我总是非常感谢——
Yeah, me, too.
是的，我也是。
--that I was tall.
——我个子高。
About 40 years ago, when Jessica was working as a salesperson for a company that sold newsprint to publications like the Washington Post, she sat down next to Donald Trump on an airplane.
大约 40 年前，当杰西卡作为一家为《华盛顿邮报》等出版物销售新闻纸的公司的销售员工作时，她在飞机上坐在了唐纳德·特朗普旁边。
Let me just say that if you have never Zoomed with a silver-haired, soigné 78-year-old woman who describes what it's like being strapped in a seat on a Braniff Airlines flight with a future president of the United States trying to fasten his lips on her like a 6' 2" suckfish-- well, in my opinion, you have not lived, let alone Zoomed, at all.
让我说一句，如果你从未与一位银发、优雅的 78 岁女性进行过 Zoom 交谈，她描述了被束缚在布兰尼夫航空公司的航班座位上，一位未来的美国总统试图像 6 英尺 2 英寸的吸鱼一样把嘴唇贴在她身上是什么感觉——嗯，在我看来，你根本没有活过，更不用说在 Zoom 上谈话了。
But before we board that flight, a refresher. Jessica was one of the first women to publicly accuse Trump of sexual assault in 2016. It was on the front page of The New York Times.
但在我们登上那次航班之前，先复习一下。杰西卡是 2016 年第一批公开指控特朗普性侵犯的女性之一。那是在《纽约时报》的头版。
I knew if the story did get any attention, that the first thing Trump would say is that I wasn't pretty enough.
我知道如果这个故事引起任何关注，特朗普说的第一件事就是我不够漂亮。
Right.
对。
I knew instinctively that that's what he was going to say.
我本能地知道他会这么说。
How did Jessica know? Because Jessica is an old bat. Old bats are the best, even better than screech owls. I'm an old bat myself. We old bats don't kid ourselves. And, in fact, one day after The New York Times published the story about what happened to Jessica on that plane in 1980, Trump yammered about her accusations at a rally.
杰西卡是怎么知道的？因为杰西卡是个老顽固。老顽固是最棒的，甚至比尖叫猫头鹰还要好。我自己也是个老顽固。我们这些老顽固不会自欺欺人。事实上，《纽约时报》报道了杰西卡 1980 年在飞机上发生的事情后的第二天，特朗普在一次集会上对她的指控大吵大闹。
Oh, I was with Donald Trump in 1980. I was sitting with him on an airplane. And he went after me on the plane. Yeah, I'm going to go after-- believe me, she would not be my first choice, that I can tell you. You don't know. That would not be my first choice.
哦，我 1980 年和唐纳德·特朗普在一起。我坐在飞机上和他在一起。他在飞机上对我动手动脚。是的，我要对……相信我，她不会是我的第一选择，我可以告诉你。你不知道。那不会是我的第一选择。
I told Jessica the same thing happened to me.
我告诉杰西卡同样的事情也发生在我身上。
I knew it was coming, too. I knew it, of course. And then he said it about me. She's not my type. Because they're running pictures of me when I'm 75 years old. And it's not fair. If they had run pictures of me as I looked-- you and I caught tons of shit because we're older women.
我也知道它要来了。我当然知道。然后他对我说了同样的话。她不是我的类型。因为他们放出了我 75 岁时的照片。这不公平。如果他们放出了我年轻时的照片——你和我都因为我们是年长的女性而受到了很多指责。
For the honor of Jessica Leeds and old bats everywhere, Jessica is a beauty now, and she was a beauty 40 years ago when she got on that flight to New York. And as she remembers it, it was a Braniff flight. Braniff was the chic airline. Her seat would have been full grain leather. Her flight attendant would have been clad in Halston. And her plane, it would have been painted in Perseus Green, Mercury Blue, or Sparkling Burgundy.
为了杰西卡·利兹和所有地方的老顽固的荣誉，杰西卡现在是个美女，40 年前她登上那架飞往纽约的航班时也是个美女。正如她记忆中的那样，那是一次布兰尼夫航空的航班。她的座位应该是全粒面皮革的。她的空姐应该穿着哈尔斯顿设计的衣服。她的飞机，应该被漆成英仙座绿、水星蓝或闪亮勃艮第酒红。
And so what were you wearing? Do you remember, when you got on that plane?
那你当时穿什么？你还记得吗，当你登上那架飞机的时候？
Yep. I had my best suit, was a brown tweed. Oh, I love that suit. And it was jacket and a skirt. It was a fabulous outfit. It really was. I never wore it again after that day, though. I hung on to it for quite a while, but I never wore it again.
记得。我穿着我最好的西装，是棕色的粗花呢。哦，我爱那套西装。那是夹克和裙子。那是一套很棒的衣服。真的是。那天之后我就再也没穿过它了，虽然。我保留了它很长一段时间，但我再也没穿过它。
I know exactly what she means. It was the same for me with the dress I had on at Bergdorf's.
我完全明白她的意思。我和我在波道夫百货穿的那件衣服是一样的。
I didn't want to throw it away because it was a beautiful Donna Karan. I would never throw it away. But I couldn't put it on because bad things happened in that dress.
我不想把它扔掉，因为它是一件漂亮的唐娜·卡伦。我永远不会把它扔掉。但我不能穿它，因为那件衣服上发生了坏事。
Yeah, exactly.
是的，完全正确。
OK, so isn't that interesting? We have so much in common. So, all right. So you were-- now tell me what happened. You get on the plane.
好吧，这不很有趣吗？我们有这么多共同点。好吧。那你当时是——现在告诉我发生了什么。你上了飞机。
I get on the plane, and I was sitting in the back. And I remember watching the stewardess come walking down the aisle. And she saw me, and she said, would you like to come up to first class? We have space. Never occurred to me not to say yes. And I gathered my purse, and I went up to first class. That had happened before.
我上了飞机，我坐在后面。我记得看着空姐顺着过道走过来。她看见我，说，你想上头等舱吗？我们有空间。我从来没想过不答应。我收拾好钱包，上了头等舱。那种事以前也发生过。
Yeah, it's happened to me, too.
是的，我也遇到过。
Yeah, I kind of accepted the fact that it was entertainment for the big honchos up in first class.
是的，我接受了这样一个事实：这是给头等舱大人物的娱乐活动。
Now I don't understand if people understand what we're talking about, but that's what they did. They chose the best looking, best dressed people, and put them up in first.
现在我不明白人们是否理解我们在谈论什么，但他们就是那样做的。他们挑选最好看、穿着最好的人，把他们放进头等舱。
That's right.
没错。
What we're talking about is how things used to be-- buying a ticket, putting on our best clothes, hopping on a cocktail party, heading for New York or Chicago or Miami or any jazzy city, USA. And this party lacked zip unless somebody very rich or very pretty was present.
我们谈论的是过去的事情——买票，穿上我们最好的衣服，跳上一场鸡尾酒会，前往纽约或芝加哥或迈阿密或美国任何热闹的城市。除非有非常富有或非常漂亮的人在场，否则这场派对就缺乏活力。
Men in first class would size up the female passengers before boarding and hold a brief conference with the check-in crew. Or, alternatively, a helpful flight attendant would simply stand in the aisle, waving people away and rearranging the seating chart so that an extremely tall chap, for instance, with black hair like greased felt could have the spot by me, which is what I told Jessica had happened on a jumbo jet to LA.
头等舱的男人会在登机前打量女乘客，并与登机人员进行简短的会议。或者，另外，一位乐于助人的空姐会直接站在过道里，挥手让人离开并重新安排座位图，这样，例如，一个有着像涂了油的毛毡一样的黑头发的个子特别高的家伙就可以坐在我旁边，这就是我告诉杰西卡在去洛杉矶的喷气式飞机上发生的事情。
After the plane took off, following the meal, the chap shows me a photo of his private plane. Then he shows me a photo of his Rolls Royce. Then he shows me his erection.
飞机起飞后，用餐后，那个家伙给我看了他私人飞机的照片。然后他给我看了他劳斯莱斯的照片。然后他给我看了他的勃起。
It would never have occurred to me to call anybody and say anything! We grew up expecting men to make a pass at-- I was not surprised. I expected it from men. Jessica, you and I were born during the Second World War. We did not report. We expected it, and we laughed. But we were wrong. We were wrong. We should have spoken up, like they're doing now.
我从来没想过要给任何人打电话说什么！我们成长过程中期望男人会有这种举动——我并不惊讶。我期望男人会这样。杰西卡，你和我出生在第二次世界大战期间。我们没有报告。我们期望它，我们笑了。但我们错了。我们错了。我们应该像他们现在这样大声疾呼。
Well, we were so thankful, though, to have--
嗯，我们非常感谢，虽然，有——
Oh, I know, to have the fucking job.
哦，我知道，有那份该死的工作。
Yep. Oh, absolutely.
是的。哦，绝对。
Oh my lord.
哦，天哪。
The flight attendant escorts Jessica to the front of the plane. She sits down in the aisle seat beside Donald Trump.
空姐护送杰西卡到飞机前部。她坐在唐纳德·特朗普旁边的过道座位上。
As I recall, he introduced himself. The name meant nothing to me.
我记得，他做了自我介绍。这个名字对我来说什么也不是。
It wouldn't have. This was 1979, 1980. Jessica wasn't a native New Yorker. And she was not yet aware of all the levels, the ranks, the spheres of New York society that Trump, a young rat out of Queens, was chewing his way through.
那不会是的。那是 1979 年，1980 年。杰西卡不是土生土长的纽约人。她还不知道纽约社会的所有层面、等级、领域，特朗普，那个来自皇后区的年轻老鼠，正啃噬着穿过。
He was very good looking in 1980, do you agree?
他 1980 年很帅，你同意吗？
Well--
嗯——
I found him very attractive in 1996. He was very pretty.
我发现他在 1996 年非常有吸引力。他很漂亮。
Yeah, I guess. I--
是的，我想。我——
He was not ugly.
他不丑。
I can remember-- I don't remember my reaction. He was perfectly reasonable when I first sat down. I mean, he was blonde, tall, good-sized man, that sort of stuff. But I don't remember being overwhelmed by his looks or--
我记得——我不记得我的反应。我刚坐下时他表现得非常合理。我的意思是，他金发、个子高、身材魁梧，那种东西。但我不记得被他的长相惊艳到或者——
Did he ask you about yourself?
他问过你的事吗？
What did we talk about? We talked about him. I remember we took off, and they served this wonderful meal. And then they came, and they picked up everything. And within a short amount of time, all of a sudden, he's on me like a wet blanket.
我们谈了什么？我们谈论了他。我记得我们起飞了，他们供应了这顿美餐。然后他们来了，把一切都收走了。没过多久，突然之间，他就像一块湿毛毯一样压在我身上。
Did he try to kiss you first?
他先试着亲吻你了吗？
Yes. Yes.
是的。是的。
She glances away from the screen with a revolted wince.
她带着反感的抽搐从屏幕上移开目光。
It was such a shock. It was like, all of a sudden, he's on me.
这太令人震惊了。就像，突然之间，他就在我身上。
Jessica is ladylike. Therefore, allow me-- for I have experience with Trump-- to say in plain English what I believe Trump is about to do. I believe he will go straight for the crotch, just like he brags on the Access Hollywood tape. This man who today claims that he has never kissed or groped a woman without consent.
杰西卡很有淑女风度。因此，允许我——因为我有特朗普的经验——用简单的英语说出我认为特朗普即将做的事情。我相信他会直奔裤裆，就像他在 Access Hollywood 录像带中吹嘘的那样。这个今天声称他在未经同意的情况下从未亲吻或抚摸过女人的男人。
It's like he's got four extra hands, because he's grabbing my breasts, he's trying to kiss me. I'm trying to get his hands off of me. And this kind of struggle went on for a little while. And then, it's when he started to put his hand up my skirt that I got a jolt of strength and managed to wiggle myself out of the seat.
就像他长了四只多余的手一样，因为他在抓我的胸部，他在试图亲吻我。我试图把他的手从我身上拿开。这种挣扎持续了一会儿。然后，就在他开始把手伸进我的裙子时，我得到了一股力量，并设法让自己从座位上扭动了出来。
Jessica grabs her purse and storms to the back of the plane.
杰西卡抓起她的钱包，冲向飞机的后面。
Now wait-- so did he make it all the way to your panties or not?
等一下——那你当时有没有被他摸到内裤？
No. No.
没有。没有。
Because you had, by that time, started to stand up, right?
因为你当时已经开始站起来了，对吧？
Right.
对。
Was there anybody else?
还有其他人吗？
Yeah, there was the guy across the aisle whose eyes were about the size of a saucer. And I kept thinking--
是的，过道对面有个家伙，他的眼睛大概有碟子那么大。我一直想——
Ah!
啊！
--why don't you say something? Or where is the stewardess on this whole thing? Why doesn't somebody come and rescue me? And that's when I realized, there was only me that was going to rescue me. So that's when I--
——你为什么不说什么？或者空姐在哪里？为什么没有人来救我？那时我意识到，只有我能救我自己。所以那就是我——
Well, I'm glad you thought of-- see, some women freeze in this situation.
嗯，我很高兴你想到了——看，有些女性在这种情况下会冻住。
Yes. Yes, I know.
是的。是的，我知道。
You didn't freeze.
你没有冻住。
No. No. But I certainly didn't say anything.
不。不。但我当然什么也没说。
I didn't say anything either! I didn't scream! I didn't do shit. I laughed. Did you laugh?
我也什么都没说！我没有尖叫！我什么都没做。我笑了。你笑了吗？
Yeah. No, I don't recall laughing. No. I took it seriously. I mean, this was a real physical attack. And--
是的。不，我不记得笑了。不。我认真对待了它。我的意思是，这是一次真正的身体攻击。而且——
Oh, I know it's an attack, an assault.
哦，我知道这是一次攻击，一次袭击。
Yeah.
是的。
Although we talk about Trump groping women, most people don't understand how brazen Trump really is because no one knows what groping means. It's one of the reasons I wanted to talk to the Trump accusers. Who knows what the heck Trump is actually doing or on what part of the female body he is doing it?
虽然我们谈论特朗普抚摸女性，但大多数人并不理解特朗普到底有多厚颜无耻，因为没人知道抚摸意味着什么。这是我想要和特朗普的指控者谈话的原因之一。谁知道特朗普实际上在做什么，或者他在女性身体的哪个部位做这件事？
One of Trump's accusers described for me Trump putting his hand up her skirt and onto her vulva. And she used the plain English. "It was like a squish," she said. "A squeeze." And she made a motion with her hand like squeezing a rubber duck. That is groping.
其中一位特朗普的指控者描述了特朗普把手伸进她的裙子并放在她的外阴上。她用了简单的英语。“就像挤压，”她说。“一种挤压。”她用手做了一个像挤橡皮鸭的动作。那就是抚摸。
So why does Trump do it? Jessica and I ponder.
那么特朗普为什么要这样做呢？杰西卡和我深思。
Let's try to figure this out. The main question is, he knows he's not going to be able to have intercourse with you on the plane. He knows this. Why does he do this? What did he think he was going to gain? Was it sexual? Were you turning him on to such an extent that he couldn't stand it? What was it?
让我们试着弄清楚这一点。主要问题是，他知道他在飞机上不可能和你发生性关系。他知道这一点。他为什么要这样做？他认为他能得到什么？那是性吗？你让他如此兴奋以至于他无法忍受吗？那是什么？
Well, personally, I can't-- I thought he was bored.
嗯，我个人，我不能——我以为他很无聊。
Oh.
哦。
Nothing happening, so let's grab a little pussy here, you know.
没什么事发生，所以让我们在这里抓点什么，你知道的。
This is such an insight to me! This is such an insight. Got it.
这对我来说是一个洞察力！这真是一个洞察力。明白了。
But it goes along with his Hollywood tape.
但这与他的好莱坞录像带相吻合。
And he has no attention span.
而且他没有注意力跨度。
No, no.
不，不。
Was he reading at all beforehand?
他事先有在读书吗？
No.
不。
Didn't he have a book?
他没带书吗？
No.
没有。
Newspaper?
报纸？
Nope.
没有。
Who'd get on a plane in 1980 without a ton of magazines, newspapers, or The Wall Street Journal?
谁在 1980 年上飞机时不带一大堆杂志、报纸或《华尔街日报》？
Exactly.
确切地。
And he had nothing to read?
他没什么可读的吗？
Nope.
没有。
You said he was bored. That is an insight that I think-- it really sends it home. Because some people have claimed he does it for power. I don't think it has anything to do with power.
你说他很无聊。我认为这是一个见解——它真的很到位。因为有些人声称他是为了权力而这样做。我不认为这与权力有任何关系。
Well, it could be. But I really kind of just chalked it off to him being bored.
嗯，可能是。但我真的只是把它归因于他太无聊了。
So Trump grabs one woman. Then he grabs the next woman and the next woman. And pretty soon, we start thinking Trump grabbing women is normal. Then Trump grabbing women becomes so normal, it's boring.
所以特朗普抓住一个女人。然后他抓住下一个女人和再下一个女人。很快，我们开始认为特朗普抓住女人是正常的。然后特朗普抓住女人变得如此正常，以至于很无聊。
It is old news, and there's so much that he's done.
这是旧闻了，他做了这么多事。
But Jessica, it's not old news. We're the most current thing. We tried to warn people. We tried to warn America this is who he was. And so now we seem to have been forgotten. We've been pushed-- well, we've been ignored. And this drives me crazy. This is why we're doing this. We're doing it between now and the election. That is our duty to once again tell America what this man is like.
但杰西卡，这不是旧闻。我们是最新的事情。我们试图警告人们。我们试图警告美国这就是他的本来面目。所以现在我们似乎被遗忘了。我们被推到——好吧，我们被忽视了。这让我发疯。这就是我们为什么这样做。我们在这场选举之前做这件事。那是我们的职责再次告诉美国这个男人是什么样的。
Well, some people may have forgotten us, but you know who has not forgotten us? The men who are voting for Trump because he grabbed us, because he is macho, because Trump proved he can paw any woman he wants. And you know who else has not forgotten? Women like Jessica and I. We'll never forget.
嗯，有些人可能已经忘记了我们，但你知道谁没有忘记我们吗？那些投票给特朗普的男人，因为他抓了我们，因为他是大男子主义，因为特朗普证明了他可以抚摸他想要的任何女人。而且你知道谁还没忘记吗？像杰西卡和我这样的女性。我们永远不会忘记。
How often did you think about this between then and 2015, when he came to the fore again, you know?
从那时到 2015 年他再次出现，你多久想一次这件事？
I probably would not have had it so emblazoned in my mind if it hadn't been for the gala at Saks Fifth Avenue.
如果不是因为萨克斯第五大道的晚会，我可能不会在脑海里记得那么深刻。
The gala at Saks Fifth Avenue. This is a year or two after the flight, and it's a benefit for the Humane Society of New York and a few other charities. Jessica is the assistant to the president of the Humane Society and is handing out table assignments.
萨克斯第五大道的晚会。这是飞行后一两年，是为纽约人道协会和其他一些慈善机构筹款。杰西卡是人道协会主席的助理，负责分配座位。
I had this fabulous dress.
我穿了这件漂亮的衣服。
Oh, what was it? Let me hear.
哦，是什么？让我听听。
Mary McFadden--
玛丽·麦克法登——
Oh, I love Mary McFadden.
哦，我爱玛丽·麦克法登。
--pleated, all these little pleats in a taxicab yellow. And I show up at Saks, and I've got this great dress on. And I'm doing my thing. And I'm meeting Geoffrey Beene. I'm meeting Bill Blass. I'm meeting all of these designers for this party. And in fact, Mary McFadden came up and looked at me and said, that's my dress. And I said, yes, it is. So it was really a fabulous evening.
——百褶，所有这些出租车黄色的小褶子。我出现在萨克斯，我穿着这件很棒的衣服。我在做我的事。我在见杰弗里·比恩。我在见比尔·布拉斯。我为这个派对见所有这些设计师。事实上，玛丽·麦克法登走过来看着我说，那是我的裙子。我说，是的，是。所以那真是一个精彩的夜晚。
And then Trump with his wife, Ivana, came up. She was pregnant, very pregnant. And he looked at me when I handed him his table assignment. And I'm looking at him, thinking, you're the asshole from the airplane. I remember you.
然后特朗普和他的妻子伊凡娜走了过来。她怀孕了，肚子很大。当我递给他座位分配时，他看着我。我看着他，心想，你就是飞机上那个混蛋。我记得你。
The future president of the United States remembers Jessica, too.
这位未来的美国总统也记得杰西卡。
And he looked at me, and he said, "I remember you. You're the cunt from the airplane."
他看着我说：“我记得你。你就是飞机上那个婊子。”
E. Jean Carroll, she's a journalist and the author of the memoir, What Do We Need Men For, her series of conversations with women who accuse Donald Trump of sexual assault. It's available at theatlantic.com.
E·珍·卡罗尔，她是记者，也是回忆录《我们需要男人做什么》的作者，她与指控唐纳德·特朗普性侵犯的女性进行了一系列对话。该系列可在 theatlantic.com 上获取。
[MUSIC - "DAREDEVIL" BY FIONA APPLE]
[音乐 - 菲奥娜·阿普尔的“DAREDEVIL”]
Coming up, seeing people fight over corn dogs in a grocery store leads one woman to do something that she has avoided for years. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
即将到来，看着人们在杂货店为玉米狗打架导致一名女性做了一些她多年来一直避免做的事情。那将在芝加哥公共广播电台的节目继续后的一分钟内播出。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, The Unreality of Now. As we approach this historic and momentous election day, we have stories of people trying to get their heads around and adapt to this strange time we are living through. We've arrived at Act Two of our program. Act Two, The Gun Reality of Now.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目是“当下的非现实”。随着我们接近这个具有历史意义和重大的选举日，我们讲述了一些试图理解并适应我们正在经历的这个奇怪时代的人们的故事。我们已经到达节目的第二幕。第二幕，当下的枪支现实。
One sign of how shaken up people are in our country right now-- gun sales. They're going nuts. A record year, according to the FBI. The FBI is doing twice the number of background checks they did last year. A survey of gun store owners by an industry trade group estimates that something like 40% of their sales are to first-time gun buyers-- 40% to people who've never owned a gun. Lilly Sullivan talked to some of them, and it was like a tour of different fears that people have about this country right now.
人们对我们国家现状感到震惊的一个迹象——枪支销售。它们正变得疯狂。据联邦调查局称，这是创纪录的一年。联邦调查局进行的背景调查数量是去年的两倍。一个行业贸易组织对枪支店主的调查估计，他们约 40% 的销售额是给首次买枪的人——40% 给从未拥有过枪支的人。莉莉·沙利文和他们中的一些人谈过，就像是对人们现在对这个国家的不同恐惧的一次巡回考察。
The thing I wanted to know was, why now? What's the thing that made you want a gun? Brian told me he was around guns some when he was growing up. He'd sometimes do target practice or go shooting. When he was 16, he was hunting with his family, and he killed a deer. It made him really sad. So he never bought a gun.
我想知道的是，为什么现在？是什么让你想要一把枪？布莱恩告诉我他在成长过程中接触过枪支。他有时会进行目标练习或去射击。他 16 岁时和家人打猎，他杀死了一只鹿。这让他非常难过。所以他从没买过枪。
Now he's 52 and lives in Steamboat Springs, Colorado. It's in the mountains, kind of a ski town in the winter. He just bought a gun the day I talked to him, a Glock 9 millimeter. The thing that made him want one? The first presidential debate, the one where there was so much yelling.
现在他 52 岁，住在科罗拉多州的斯廷博特斯普林斯。那是在山区，冬天有点滑雪胜地。他就在我采访他的那天买了一把枪，一把格洛克 9 毫米手枪。让他想要一把枪的事情？第一次总统辩论，那场有很多大喊大叫的辩论。
After watching that debate, I laughed out loud multiple times, but at the same time, I was horrified.
看完那场辩论，我多次大声笑出来，但同时，我感到恐惧。
What was it about the debate?
辩论有什么特别之处？
Oh, I think it was just the non-civility. It wasn't civil. I mean, Biden was trying to be civil. But the leader of our country was not trying to be civil. I mean, whoever thought our country would come to this to where it almost seems like it-- I mean, I don't know if it's leading towards a civil war, but it's not-- it doesn't seem civil.
哦，我想这只是不文明。它不文明。我的意思是，拜登试图保持文明。但我们国家的领导人并没有试图保持文明。我的意思是，谁会想到我们的国家会变成这样，几乎看起来像是它——我的意思是，我不知道它是否正走向内战，但它不是——它看起来不文明。
Everybody on my side, we're mad. Everybody on that side, they're mad. I mean, it's-- I don't know after the election if-- if the Republicans are going to take this very well if they lose. Trump's already saying that-- he hasn't said he's going to accept any kind of-- I mean, it's going to be challenged. And then you get-- I think there's going to be-- I mean, there's going to be people protesting.
我这边的每个人，我们都很生气。那边每个人，他们都很生气。我的意思是，它——我不知道选举后如果——如果共和党人输了，他们会很好地接受吗。特朗普已经在说——他还没有说他会接受任何形式的——我的意思是，它将被质疑。然后你会得到——我认为会有——我的意思是，会有人们抗议。
Protesting the election, you mean?
你是说抗议选举？
Yeah, the results. And I mean, it's just-- and you know what? And those people that are going to be protesting the results-- I mean, I hope they don't become violent. But they're all Second Amendment, gun-toting Americans, you know?
是的，结果。我的意思是，这只是——你知道吗？那些将抗议结果的人——我的意思是，我希望他们不要变得暴力。但他们都是第二修正案的持枪美国人，你知道吗？
And I don't know. And I think I'm fine in my small little town that I live in. But I mean, you just never know. I actually went and looked at guns at one gun shop on the Thursday after the debate. And they were out. They were out of guns. They were out of ammo.
我不知道。我想我在我居住的小城镇里很好。但我的意思是，你永远不知道。辩论后的周四，我实际上去了一家枪支商店看枪。他们卖光了。他们的枪卖光了。他们的弹药卖光了。
I get online, and I looked at stores in Denver and stuff like that even. Sold out, sold out, sold out, sold out, sold out, sold out. Unbelievable.
我上网，我甚至看了丹佛之类的商店。售罄，售罄，售罄，售罄，售罄，售罄。不可思议。
And so then I found another place. It's like an hour from home. And they had guns. It's a weird thing because I feel like I go to the gun counter. And first off, there's the whole mask, non-masked libtard thing. So yeah, it felt weird, because you're talking to a bunch of gun-toting Republicans trying to buy a gun off of them. So then I'm there in cut-off sweatpants and a hoodie, wearing a mask. And so, yeah, it's a little bit--
所以我找到了另一个地方。离家一个小时路程。他们有枪。这是一件奇怪的事情，因为我觉得我去柜台买枪。首先，有戴口罩、不戴口罩的“自由派白痴”那档子事。所以是的，这感觉很奇怪，因为你在和一群持枪的共和党人谈话，试图从他们那里买枪。所以我就穿着剪短的运动裤和连帽衫，戴着口罩在那里。所以，是的，这有点——
You said "libtard?"
你说“自由派白痴”？
Oh, I've heard that so much. And I went into my local gun shop, where masks should be required, according to the ordinances. And I was in there talking to the kid. He had a pistol on his side. It looked like he was definitely not voting for the same person I'm voting for. And he did not have a mask on. And his dad who owned the shop did not have a mask on.
哦，我听过很多次了。我去了我当地的枪店，根据条例，应该要求戴口罩。我在那里和那个孩子谈话。他腰上有一把手枪。看起来他绝对不会投票给我要投的那个人。他没戴口罩。拥有商店的他的父亲也没戴口罩。
Then the kid's-- after I'm in there for a couple minutes, he's like, you don't have to wear your mask. And I'm like, uh, yeah, I'll go ahead and just keep my mask on if you don't mind. And he kind of paused, and he got choked up on, like, he was going to say some stuff. And I was finally like, no, we don't need to discuss it. I just have some questions about these guns. And he kind of wasn't as nice to me after that.
然后那孩子——我在那待了几分钟后，他说，你不必戴口罩。我说，呃，是的，如果你不介意的话，我会继续戴着口罩。他停顿了一下，他哽咽了，好像，他要说些什么。我最后说，不，我们不需要讨论它。我只是对这些枪有一些疑问。在那之后他对我没那么友好了。
Oh, really? You think you maybe irritated him a little or something.
哦，真的吗？你觉得你可能稍微激怒了他之类的。
Yeah, like, because I was a libtard in his store looking at guns. So I guess now I'm a gun-toting libtard.
是的，就像，因为我是他店里的“自由派白痴”在看枪。所以我猜现在我是持枪的“自由派白痴”了。
For DeJonae, the moment she decided to buy a gun happened in March. She's a nurse in San Bernardino County, outside of LA. DeJonae has an aunt who wanted her to get a gun for years. Her aunt owns a gun store. It's actually the only Black-owned gun store on the West Coast, where she trains women to shoot. DeJonae is pretty, her aunt told me. She worries about her niece dating and living alone. DeJonae had even had a stalker once.
对于德乔娜来说，她决定买枪的时刻发生在三月。她是洛杉矶外圣贝纳迪诺县的一名护士。德乔娜有一个姨妈，多年来一直想让她买把枪。她姨妈经营一家枪支商店。它实际上是西海岸唯一一家黑人拥有的枪支商店，她在那里训练女性射击。她姨妈告诉我，德乔娜很漂亮。她担心她的侄女约会和独自生活。德乔娜甚至曾经有一个跟踪者。
But the thing that flipped DeJonae wasn't the stalker. She was in the grocery store after work one day. The pandemic had just arrived.
但让德乔娜转变的事情不是那个跟踪者。有一天她下班后在杂货店。大流行刚刚到来。
I've never seen the grocery store look the way that it looked-- lines wrapped around the building, people beating people up for their groceries or for their baskets because there were none. Everywhere. And it was just like complete pandemonium.
我从未见过杂货店那个样子——队伍绕着大楼，人们为了他们的杂货或篮子互相殴打，因为里面没有了。到处都是。就像彻底的混乱。
Did you say beating people up? Like, fighting?
你说殴打人们？像，打架？
Yeah, people were getting into fights-- physical fights.
是的，人们发生了争执——身体上的争执。
So wait, what were people fighting about?
等等，人们在为什么打架？
The last sanitizer. I mean, but there's not-- it wasn't just one. There were a couple of them. People were fighting over the last pack of tissue, literally the last pack of frozen corn dogs. Everyone was buying everything that they could put their hands on. And I just remember looking at all these people, and it just made me scared. I said, wow, I'm scared.
最后一点消毒剂。我的意思是，但没有——那不是只有一个。有好几个。人们在抢最后一包纸巾，真的是最后一包冷冻玉米狗。每个人都在买他们能拿到手的一切。我只记得看着所有这些人，这让我感到害怕。我说，哇，我很害怕。
So I called my aunt, and I said, hey, I need to buy a gun. And she started laughing. And I said, what do you have? And then I sent her the money right there. And--
所以我打电话给我的姨妈，我说，嘿，我需要买把枪。她开始笑。我说，你有什么？然后我当场就给她发了钱。而且——
Like, online?
像，在线？
Yeah, I Zelled it to her. I Zelled her the money. And I'm like, I already paid for it. This is mine. Put it aside.
是的，我通过 Zelle 转给她了。我通过 Zelle 把钱给她了。我说，我已经付钱了。这是我的。把它放在一边。
A lot of first-time gun owners I talked to explain their reason this way. They had started to feel something weird in the air, a kind of amorphous anxiety.
我和许多首次买枪的人谈过，他们这样解释自己的理由。他们开始感觉到空气中有一种奇怪的东西，一种模糊的焦虑。
Shane is 49. He has a house in the hills in Northern California. So in addition to all the coronavirus strangeness, they've also had wildfires and rolling blackouts. One day, a few months ago, the power went out. And it didn't come back for 14 days, which meant no internet. And then the cell towers stopped working.
肖恩 49 岁。他在北加州的山里有一所房子。所以除了所有冠状病毒的奇怪之处外，他们还经历了野火和滚动停电。几个月前的一天，电源中断了。而且 14 天没恢复，这意味着没有互联网。然后手机信号塔停止工作。
So things started getting weird. That's the best way that we can put it, is things started getting weird. People would drive right up to the grocery store. Not park, just literally drive right up and nose first, right in front of the doors for the grocery store, and get out and just leave their car there.
所以事情开始变得奇怪。这是我们能表达的最好的方式，就是事情开始变得奇怪了。人们会直接开车到杂货店。不停车，只是字面上直接开过去，车头朝前，就在杂货店大门前，然后下车把车留在那里。
You mean those sliding doors?
你是说那些滑动门？
Yeah. So there was, like, fraying. There was just a feeling. There was just a feeling in the air that was not a good feeling. You could pick up that things were getting kind of weird and were going to get weirder if the power didn't come on soon.
是的。所以有，像，摩擦。有一种感觉。空气中有一种感觉，不是一种好的感觉。你可以感觉到事情变得有点奇怪，如果电力不快点恢复，情况会变得更糟。
I asked Shane and everyone else, when you think about needing a gun, what do you picture? Is there a scene that plays in your mind? Nearly everyone said it's night. They're sleeping, and someone dangerous shows up.
我问肖恩和其他人，当你想到需要一把枪时，你想象的是什么？你脑海里有什么场景吗？几乎每个人都说那是夜晚。他们在睡觉，某个危险的人出现了。
Shane's version is people wandering to his house in a disaster, finding it in the woods through the smoke, and trying to take his family's supplies, their food, their generator, the things they need to survive. There's something pre-apocalyptic about it. He's on his own, protecting his home from marauders.
肖恩的版本是人们在灾难中游荡到他家，在烟雾中通过森林发现它，并试图拿走他家人的物资，他们的食物，他们的发电机，他们生存需要的东西。它有一种前启示录的感觉。他独自一人，保护他的家免受掠夺者的伤害。
This is stuff he doesn't think will happen. But at the same time, for months, they've been surrounded by fires, smoke so thick that it can look like dusk in the middle of the day. So somehow, it does seem possible to him. All kinds of things do.
这是他认为不会发生的事情。但与此同时，几个月来，他们一直被火灾包围，烟雾如此浓重，以至于在白天看起来就像黄昏。所以不知何故，这对他来说似乎是可能的。各种各样的事情都是。
I wonder if there are people who-- in our community, who resent us because we're successful or for whatever reason, because we're Jews or because we're gay and-- you know. We do have a growing neo-Nazi threat in this country. It's our biggest internal security danger, is the growth of neo-Nazis. And those people know how to use firearms.
我想知道是否有——在我们的社区里，怨恨我们的人，因为我们成功或者因为任何原因，因为我们是犹太人或者因为我们是同性恋，你知道。我们这个国家确实有日益增长的新纳粹威胁。这是我们内部最大的安全危险，就是新纳粹的增长。而那些人知道如何使用枪支。
So but my feeling is, if you're on the left or even a moderate, you should be doing the same thing to protect yourself. My husband's been a little out of control with the ammunition. He's purchased, like, 1,600 rounds.
所以但我的感觉是，如果你在左翼或者甚至是中间派，你应该做同样的事情来保护自己。我的丈夫在弹药方面有点失控。他买了大约 1600 发子弹。
And I said, Glenn, after a gun battle involving 1,600 rounds, your gun, A, would melt because the barrel would get so hot, you'd have to stop firing after a certain point. And I said our house would probably collapse. It'd look like Swiss cheese. The walls would collapse inward on themselves.
我说，格伦，在涉及 1600 发子弹的枪战后，你的枪，A，会融化，因为枪管会变得太热，你必须在某个点后停止射击。我说我们的房子可能会倒塌。它看起来会像瑞士奶酪。墙壁会向内坍塌。
But he's like, it's just hard to find ammunition for this gun. And I'm like, I'm fine with about 75 rounds. I don't feel like I need 1,600 rounds of ammunition. And I actually asked him to please stop buying ammunition, but--
但他就像，这把枪很难找到弹药。我说，我 75 发子弹就够了。我觉得我不需要 1600 发弹药。我实际上要求他停止购买弹药，但是——
Oh my gosh.
哦天哪。
--he did really stock up. [LAUGHS]
——他确实囤积了很多。[笑]
OK, I'm trying to picture 1,600 rounds. Is that, like, a shoe box full of bullets?
好的，我正在试图想象 1600 发子弹。那是，像，一个装满子弹的鞋盒吗？
We actually did buy some Gucci flats. And that box was filled up with bullets. It's kind of an incongruous look, the Gucci shoe box with the 22 bullets. That's a gay male way of doing it.
我们确实买了一些 Gucci 平底鞋。那个盒子里装满了子弹。这看起来有点不协调，Gucci 鞋盒配 22 颗子弹。这是一种同性恋男性的做法。
Nancy bought her pistol around Mother's Day. She send me a photo of herself on Mother's Day, dressed in a Lilly Pulitzer blouse and pale blue cardigan, holding a Smith and Wesson 380 EZ. She's 53. She owns a small business making luggage tags. She's also worked as a nurse a lot in hospice.
南希在母亲节前后买了她的手枪。她发给我一张她在母亲节的照片，穿着莉莉·普利策上衣和淡蓝色开衫，拿着一把史密斯威森 380 EZ。她 53 岁。她拥有一个小企业制作行李标签。她也曾在临终关怀中做过很多护士工作。
She lives with her family just outside of Appleton, Wisconsin. She described her town to me as your typical, don't-have-to-lock-your-door suburb. Before this year, she'd never even held a gun. It was actually kind of hard for her to explain why it felt so urgent.
她和家人住在威斯康星州阿普尔顿郊外。她把她的城镇描述为典型的，不用锁门的郊区。今年之前，她甚至从未拿过枪。对她来说，解释为什么感觉如此紧急其实有点困难。
It's kind of like a nameless, faceless feeling that I have, almost like the earthquake that the world had where everything shifted. And the normal that we knew is no longer there. It's like the axis. The world fell off its axis.
这有点像我有一种无名、无脸的感觉，几乎就像世界发生的地震，一切都改变了。我们所知道的常态已不复存在。就像轴心一样。世界从轴心上掉了下来。
Since the pandemic, she says, her world has suddenly shrunken to just her family and her home.
大流行以来，她说，她的世界突然缩小到只有她的家人和她的家。
That was all you had. And so if someone was going to come into your house and take that away, as everything else had been taken away, that was not OK.
这就是你所拥有的全部。所以如果有人要进入你的房子并把这些拿走，就像其他一切都被拿走了一样，那是不行的。
Nancy lives two hours north of Kenosha, Wisconsin, where there were big protests after the shooting of Jacob Blake by police officers. Some demonstrators set cars and buildings on fire. The National Guard was called in. A teenager, a Trump supporter who came to the protests in support of Blue Lives Matter, shot three people, killing two of them. There have been protests in Appleton near where Nancy lives.
南希住在威斯康星州基诺沙以北两小时路程的地方，那里发生了警察枪杀雅各布·布莱克后的大规模抗议。一些示威者纵火焚烧汽车和建筑物。国民警卫队被召集。一名青少年，一名来到抗议现场支持“蓝命也是命”的特朗普支持者，射杀了三个人，杀死了其中两人。在南希居住的阿普尔顿附近也有抗议活动。
It's this small town. Nothing happens. Nothing goes on. We don't have any murderers, but we had rioters here in Appleton. So we've got kind of a small town taste of people being upset and being-- the tension.
这是一个小城镇。什么都没发生。什么都没有进行。我们没有任何杀人犯，但我们在阿普尔顿有暴徒。所以我们对人们感到沮丧和——紧张有一种小镇的味道。
The police in Appleton don't use the word "riot" to describe what happened there. One man was assaulted, but there were no fires, no vandalism. And when Nancy and I talked about it more, she agreed that riot wasn't the right word.
阿普尔顿的警察不用“暴动”这个词来描述那里发生的事情。一个人受到了攻击，但没有火灾，没有故意破坏。当南希和我更多地谈论它时，她同意“暴动”不是正确的词。
Nancy already owned her gun by the time this happened, but a lot of gun store owners have said that customers point to the protests as one of the reasons they felt so worried.
事情发生时南希已经拥有了她的枪，但许多枪店主说，顾客将抗议活动作为他们感到如此担忧的原因之一。
I don't want to sound like a privileged white woman, that I'm living in this la-la land, which is really mostly white people here. I mean, this is almost Utah white. It's white, white here. But there has been more racial tension and more people coming in. And I don't know. I think it's the underlying fear. And I don't know who I'm afraid of. That's also kind of upsetting, too, is, I don't really know who am I afraid of. Who am I worried about?
我不想听起来像一个享有特权的白人女性，我生活在那个梦幻世界里，这里大部分确实是白人。我的意思是，这里几乎是犹他州的白。它是白，这里很白。但有更多的种族紧张关系和更多人进来。我不知道。我认为这是潜在的恐惧。我不知道我害怕谁。这也很让人心烦，我真的不知道我害怕谁。我担心谁？
Tell me more about that. What do you mean?
告诉我更多关于那个的事。你是什么意思？
I don't know. Is there somebody that's going to be coming for revenge because I'm Caucasian? Is there somebody that's coming for my property? Is there someone coming just because they feel like it?
我不知道。是否有某人因为我是高加索人而要来复仇？是否有某人因为我的财产而来？是否有某人来仅仅是因为他们想这样做？
So when you're thinking about just the unrest, are you picturing Black people? Because I also know that in Kenosha, it was a white teenager who killed two people. So I'm just kind of curious. Is it Black people? Is it white people?
所以当你想到动荡时，你想象的是黑人吗？因为我也知道在基诺沙，是一个白人青少年杀死了两个人。所以我只是有点好奇。是黑人吗？是白人吗？
Honestly, if I had to say what I was worried about is-- and this is going to sound truly awful, but I don't think it's so much a matter of a color of a skin, but more of a socioeconomic level of someone that's so desperate that-- things are so bad and people losing their job and people are unable to make their rent.
老实说，如果我必须说我担心的是什么——这听起来真的太糟糕了，但我不认为这更多是皮肤颜色的问题，而更多是处于绝望状态的某人的社会经济水平——事情太糟糕了，人们失去工作，人们无法支付房租。
And I think that's what makes me more nervous than particular Black Lives Matter or African-Americans or anything like that. I think it's more just the desperation of people. So the protests and stuff like that doesn't scare me. I think it's more just the world in general that scares me and the unrest and the uneasy feeling than anything else.
我认为这让我比特定的“黑人的命也是命”或非裔美国人或类似的事情更紧张。我认为这更多是人们的绝望。所以抗议和类似的东西并没有吓到我。我认为这更多是世界普遍吓到了我，比起其他任何事情，这种动荡和不安的感觉。
One more person. Elsa lives in a small town in North Carolina. Growing up, no one around her had guns. She grew up in Kenya, moved to the US over 30 years ago. That nightmare scenario that nearly everyone talked about of being woken up in the night by intruders, asleep and helpless, it actually happened to Elsa a couple of years ago.
再来一个人。埃尔莎住在北卡罗来纳州的一个小镇。成长过程中，她周围没有人有枪。她在肯尼亚长大，30 多年前搬到美国。几乎每个人都谈论的那个噩梦场景，即在夜里被闯入者惊醒，睡着且无助，那实际上几年前发生在埃尔莎身上。
The intruders fled before hurting anyone, but it was terrifying. She thought about getting a gun. But she didn't until this year, when COVID hit and when police violence set off protests around the country.
闯入者在伤害任何人之前逃跑了，但这太可怕了。她想过买把枪。但直到今年，当新冠病毒来袭，当警察暴力在全国引发抗议时，她才买。
I worry not about the Black Lives Matter. I worry about the crazies that are out there that are against the Black Lives Matter movement that could target someone like me just because of the color of my skin. For one, I'm mixed. And my daughter is pale, very, very-- she's got her complexion. She's got Caucasian complexion because, well, my ex-husband was white. And like I said, he's my ex-husband.
我不担心“黑人的命也是命”。我担心那些外面反对“黑人的命也是命”运动的疯子，他们可能仅仅因为我的皮肤颜色而把像我这样的人作为目标。首先，我是混血儿。而我的女儿很苍白，非常，非常——她有她的肤色。她有高加索人的肤色，因为，嗯，我的前夫是白人。就像我说的那样，他是我的前夫。
So my current husband is a Black man. Yeah, so Black woman, white child is an issue. And even worse, I feel worse for my husband because there are a lot of times that he goes out with my daughter. And my daughter is-- well, aside from her nose, she could pass for white. So him walking out with her, I can see someone trying something crazy, you know?
所以我现在的丈夫是一个黑人。是的，所以黑人女性，白人孩子是一个问题。而且更糟的是，我为我丈夫感到更糟，因为他经常和我的女儿一起出去。而我的女儿是——嗯，除了她的鼻子，她可以假装是白人。所以他和她一起走出去，我可以预见有人会尝试做些疯狂的事情，你知道吗？
Yeah.
是的。
I worry in part because of the rhetoric that I see, number one, coming from the White House. It scares me. And more and more as we're getting closer to the election, I'm more and more scared. And I've become so aware now. Everywhere I go, I make sure I have my weapon on me.
我担心部分是因为我看到的言辞，第一，来自白宫。它吓到我了。而且随着我们越来越接近选举，我越来越害怕。我现在变得如此清醒。我去任何地方，我都确保我带着我的武器。
Oh wow.
哦哇。
So I came from a third world country. Never expected the environment here to be this thick. I feel so much tension. And I fear so much. There's a lot of fear. You've got the extremists. And you don't know who they are. You don't know who they are. But it's gotten a lot worse during Trump.
所以我来自一个第三世界国家。从没想过这里的环境会这么浓。我感到如此紧张。而且我如此害怕。有很多恐惧。你有极端分子。而且你不知道他们是谁。你不知道他们是谁。但它在特朗普期间变得更糟了。
There are a lot of people that all along have tried to blend in, right?
有很多一直试图融入的人，对吧？
Yeah.
是的。
Trump came along, and a lot of the people that used to kind of try to blend in and not bring out their true feelings are now bringing out their true feelings. And they feel like they can get away with it. Whereas, before, that wasn't there.
特朗普出现了，很多曾经试图融入而不表现出真实感受的人现在表现出了他们的真实感受。而且他们觉得他们可以逃脱惩罚。而以前，那是没有的。
Do you feel like you can see things changing around you, people coming out, kind of?
你觉得你能看到周围的事物在改变，人们走出来，某种程度上？
Yeah, well, when you start seeing the Confederate flag all over you, all over around you, that's a big sign, you know? I saw one that was right on the side of the highway that didn't used to be there.
是的，嗯，当你开始看到邦联旗到处都是，到处在你周围，那是一个巨大的信号，你知道吗？我看到一个就在高速公路边上，过去没有的。
How does your husband feel about the decision to buy a gun?
你丈夫对买枪的决定感觉如何？
Uh--
呃——
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
He is completely against it.
他完全反对。
Oh, really?
哦，真的吗？
Yeah. Yeah, he's like-- I had to kind of ease it in. Yeah, 'cause he was not for it at all.
是的。是的，他就像——我不得不有点缓和。是的，因为他一点也不支持。
Why not?
为什么不？
He is completely against them. He is completely against guns. So I think he's kind of warming up to the fact that I have a couple. But yeah, he's not comfortable-- put it that way. Even when I'm cleaning it, I try not to clean it when he's around because he's just not comfortable.
他完全反对他们。他完全反对枪支。所以我认为他有点逐渐接受我有几把的事实。但是的，他不舒服——这么说吧。即使我在清洁它，我也尽量不在他身边清洁，因为他就是不舒服。
The last question I had for everyone-- now that people have their guns, does it help? Do you feel better?
我问每个人的最后一个问题——现在人们有了枪，它有帮助吗？你感觉更好吗？
100%. 100%.
100%。100%。
Again, here's DeJonae, who bought her gun when she saw people fighting over corn dogs.
同样，这是德乔娜，她在看到人们为玉米狗打架时买了枪。
I feel so much better. I could go to bed--
我感觉好多了。我可以上床——
Really?
真的吗？
--at night. Yes, 100%. You have something to protect yourself. I mean, I live alone, but I still sleep with my bedroom door closed and locked. And so--
——在晚上。是的，100%。你有东西可以保护你自己。我的意思是，我一个人住，但我睡觉时卧室门仍然关闭和锁着。所以——
Really? Huh.
真的吗？哈。
Yes, yeah, I do. Just in case, to give me a couple of extra seconds, I guess. That's how I see it. So now I'm fine.
是的，是的，我做。以防万一，给我几秒钟的缓冲，我想。我就是这么看的。所以现在我很好。
Again, here's Nancy from Wisconsin.
同样，这是来自威斯康星州的南希。
Oh gosh, yes. Just having it next to the bed. Yep, just having it next to the bed.
哦天哪，是的。把它放在床边。是的，把它放在床边。
Yeah, there's no doubt about it.
是的，毫无疑问。
Here's Shane, who worried about marauders and neo-Nazis.
这是肖恩，他担心掠夺者和新纳粹。
Being powerless is not a good place to be. It does make you feel more secure. If things really start going downhill, you're like, we can handle this. I don't worry about that anymore, which is nice.
无能为力不是一个好的处境。它确实让你感觉更安全。如果情况真的开始恶化，你会觉得，我们可以处理它。我不再担心那个了，这很好。
And finally, Brian, who had so much trouble finding a gun. He finally picked one up the day I talked to him.
最后，布莱恩，他在找枪时遇到了很多麻烦。他最终在我采访他的那天买了一把。
Does it make you feel safer?
它让你感觉更安全吗？
No, not yet. No. No. That's an interesting question because there's a gun sitting on my counter, and I got ammo next to it. And I don't know where to put it.
不，还没有。不。不。这是一个有趣的问题，因为我的柜台上放着一把枪，我旁边有弹药。我不知道该把它放在哪里。
Oh, really?
哦，真的吗？
And I'll tell you, I'm not-- let's just say the ammo is still in the ammo boxes. And the gun's still in the gun case. I'm not in a hurry to put the ammo in the-- what do they call that thing? The-- they call it something, the ammo goes in. It's-- I don't know what it's called. Because it'll hold so many bullets in it. I forget what that thing's called, but I'm just not in a hurry to put any bullets in it. I mean--
我告诉你，我不是——我们就说弹药还在弹药盒里。枪还在枪盒里。我不急着把弹药放进——他们管那玩意儿叫什么？那个——他们管它叫什么，弹药放进去的地方。它是——我不知道它叫什么。因为它里面可以装很多子弹。我忘了那玩意儿叫什么了，但我只是不急着往里面放任何子弹。我的意思是——
Got it.
明白了。
Yeah. I mean, I-- honestly, I really don't want one.
是的。我的意思是，我——老实说，我真的不想要一把。
Oh, you don't?
哦，你不要？
I mean, I don't. I just-- I almost feel like I just had to get one.
我的意思是，我不要。我只是——我几乎觉得我只是必须得有一把。
Oh, interesting. Does it kind of suck to have one?
哦，有趣。拥有一把枪是不是有点烂？
Yeah, I don't like it. I wish I didn't think-- I wish I didn't think I needed one.
是的，我不喜欢它。我希望我不认为——我希望我不认为我需要一把。
Brian told me he grew up with guns. But they were for hunting and target practice, for fun. He says nobody talked about self-defense. Nobody talked about shooting other people. But that's all anybody talks about today. That's one thing that unites us. We're united in fear of each other.
布莱恩告诉我他是在枪支环绕中长大的。但那是为了狩猎和目标练习，为了乐趣。他说没人谈论自卫。没人谈论射击其他人。但那正是今天每个人都在谈论的。那是团结我们的一件事。我们在对彼此的恐惧中团结在一起。
Lilly Sullivan is a producer on our program. Noor Gil helped her with additional reporting.
莉莉·沙利文是我们节目的制片人。努尔·吉尔为她提供了额外的报道。
[MUSIC - "I'M SCARED" BY LON MILO DUQUETTE]
[音乐 - 隆·米洛·杜奎特的“I'M SCARED”]
Act Three, Second Time's the Charm. So maybe you've heard we're trying to hold an election this year with a possible record-breaking turnout that is also during a pandemic, which has led us into a vast territory of, who knows if this is going to work? Reporter Johnny Kauffman has been embedded with the election staff in Fulton County, Georgia. That's the county with the most people in the state and with the city of Atlanta.
第三幕，第二次是魅力。所以也许你听说我们今年试图举行一场可能的破纪录投票率的选举，同时也在大流行期间，这使我们进入了一个巨大的领域，谁知道这是否会奏效？记者约翰尼·考夫曼一直嵌入在佐治亚州富尔顿县的选举工作人员中。那是该州人口最多且拥有亚特兰大市的县。
For months, Johnny's been given unusual access to the election staff, the people who are responsible for handling the mail-in ballots and the voting machines and all that stuff. He was interested in seeing how things would go this November, partly because they went so badly when they tried to hold the primary during the pandemic back in June. Here's Johnny Kauffman.
几个月来，约翰尼一直被给予非同寻常的进入选举工作人员的权限，这些人负责处理邮寄选票和投票机以及所有那些东西。他有兴趣看看今年 11 月情况会怎样，部分原因是他们在六月大流行期间试图举行初选时情况太糟糕了。这是约翰尼·考夫曼。
The primary election here was a mess. Some voters asked for mail-in ballots, but never got them. Then people who wanted to vote in person waited and waited in line.
这里的初选是一团糟。一些选民要求邮寄选票，但从未收到。然后想要亲自投票的人在队伍中等啊等。
People shouldn't have to wait three hours to vote. This is beyond ridiculous.
人们不应该等三个小时来投票。这简直太荒谬了。
One guy famously started his cell phone timer running. And by the time he voted, it was 1:00 in the morning. He'd been there almost eight hours and watched all of Curb Your Enthusiasm, Season 8 on his phone. The front page of the Atlanta Journal Constitution said, "Complete Meltdown."
一个家伙出名地启动了他的手机计时器。当他投票时，已经是凌晨 1 点了。他已经在那里等了将近八个小时，并在手机上观看了《抑制热情》第八季的所有剧集。《亚特兰大宪法报》的头版写着，“彻底崩溃”。
The state government was pretty clear whose fault they thought all this was. Brad Raffensperger, the secretary of state, said, quote, "This all lays on Fulton County." He launched an investigation into the county and asked for a new law that would let him take over county election departments if needed. The guy whose job he'd take over if he did that, the man currently running the Fulton County Elections Department, is Rick Barron.
州政府非常清楚他们认为这是谁的错。国务卿布拉德·拉芬斯佩格说，引用，“这一切都归咎于富尔顿县。”他发起了对该县的调查，并要求出台一项新法律，允许他在需要时接管县选举部门。如果他这样做，他将接管职位的家伙，目前经营富尔顿县选举部门的人，是里克·巴伦。
Whatever Secretary Raffensperger's opinion is, it's his opinion. It's his opinion alone. And I disagree with him.
无论拉芬斯佩格国务卿的意见是什么，那都是他的意见。那是他个人的意见。我不同意他的观点。
It's worth pointing out Raffensperger and the state government are Republican. Fulton County and Atlanta are controlled by Democrats. Rick started working in elections after he quit his job as a middle manager at a bank. He told me he wanted to contribute to, quote, "the betterment of man or something," end quote.
值得指出的是，拉芬斯佩格和州政府是共和党。富尔顿县和亚特兰大由民主党控制。里克在辞去银行中层管理人员的工作后开始从事选举工作。他告诉我他想为，引用，“人类的改善或什么”做出贡献，引言结束。
Rick has this quality that I think lots of people might like to see in the guy who runs their elections. He's measured and kind of boring in public. Like at press conferences, he'll just rattle off stat after stat. But during the primary, beneath that public face, Rick was full of dread.
里克拥有这种品质，我认为许多人可能希望在经营他们选举的家伙身上看到。他很克制，在公共场合有点无聊。比如在新闻发布会上，他只会罗列一个又一个统计数据。但在初选期间，在那张公众面孔下，里克充满了恐惧。
I just was constantly-- I've had this constant feeling of stress and that I was failing at my job. And it didn't seem like anything we did, uh, helped.
我只是不断地——我一直有一种持续的压力感，觉得我在工作中失败了。而且似乎我们做的任何事情，呃，都没有帮助。
One of the things that went wrong in June is that Fulton had these new touchscreen voting computers that were imposed on them by the state. And there wasn't enough time to train poll workers properly.
六月出错的事情之一是富尔顿有这些州强加给他们的新触摸屏投票电脑。没有足够的时间来正确培训投票站工作人员。
But Rick and the Fulton staff say most of the troubles in their primary were really about the pandemic. So many applications for mail-in ballots came in, the email system crashed. And then some of the staff got COVID. It slowed their operations, and they had to close the elections office to disinfect it.
但里克和富尔顿的工作人员说，初选中的大多数麻烦实际上是关于大流行的。收到了太多的邮寄选票申请，电子邮件系统崩溃了。然后一些工作人员感染了新冠。这减慢了他们的运作，他们不得不关闭选举办公室进行消毒。
Then, close to primary election day, dozens of poll workers quit, scared about the virus. Polling places like churches decided they didn't want to be polling places anymore. Tim Cummings is a manager at the warehouse where the county stores its election equipment. He told me at the last minute the Fulton staff thought about just pitching a tent in the middle of an Atlanta park.
然后，接近初选投票日，几十名投票站工作人员辞职，害怕这种病毒。像教堂这样的投票点决定他们不想再做投票点了。蒂姆·卡明斯是县储存其选举设备的仓库的一名经理。他告诉我，最后一刻，富尔顿的工作人员考虑在亚特兰大公园中间搭个帐篷。
Get people to vote there. Yeah, I mean, 'cause we were like drowning men grabbing for straws. We got to find somewhere for this to be.
让人们在那里投票。是的，我的意思是，因为我们就像淹死的人在抓稻草。我们必须找到一个地方让它成为现实。
In the middle of all this, a beloved longtime employee named Beverly Walker died. Everyone had to cope with that. She was 62 and worked in the department for 14 years. Even after she retired, she would come back to help as a temp. Here's Tim Cummings again.
在所有这些事情中，一位受人爱戴的长期员工名叫贝弗利·沃克的去世了。每个人都不得不面对这一点。她 62 岁，在部门工作了 14 年。即使在她退休后，她也会回来作为临时工帮忙。这是蒂姆·卡明斯再次发言。
I knew Beverly. We all did. We worked with her because they're here every election. There's a picture of her on the wall in my cubicle right now. They went through a lot.
我认识贝弗利。我们所有人都认识。我们和她一起工作，因为他们每次选举都在这里。我的隔间墙上现在就有一张她的照片。他们经历了很多。
And Ralph got sick, too. I didn't realize that.
拉尔夫也生病了，我没意识到。
Yeah, he was sick, too. We were worried about whether or not he was going to make it. We still had to get a job done. It wasn't easy. And some days, people were just pissed. But they came in, and they did the job.
是的，他也生病了。我们担心他是否能挺过去。我们仍然必须完成这项工作。这不容易。有些天，人们只是感到愤怒。但他们进来了，他们完成了工作。
I don't really know how to say it. It's a really bad time to make any mistake, because people right now are really unforgiving of anything.
我真的不知道怎么说。这是一个犯任何错误的非常糟糕的时刻，因为人们现在对任何事情都非常不宽容。
This is Caryn Ficklin. She runs the mail-in ballot operation for Fulton County.
这是卡琳·菲克林。她负责富尔顿县的邮寄选票运作。
They don't care what you're going through, how you're feeling, what's happening with you or anything. It's just like-- you know. Yeah, I guess it is what it is. It's the beast that we have to deal with right now.
他们不在乎你正在经历什么，你的感觉如何，你身上发生了什么或者任何事情。就像——你知道的。是的，我想就是这样。这是我们现在必须对付的野兽。
In the lead-up to the general election, the county made a bunch of changes in hopes of avoiding another meltdown like the primary. For starters, 91 more polling places on Election Day, with more training on the touchscreen voting computers for all the poll workers. Nonprofits gave them millions of dollars to help pay for all that.
在大选临近之际，该县做了一系列改变，希望能避免像初选那样的另一次崩溃。首先，选举日增加了 91 个投票点，并为所有投票站工作人员提供了更多关于触摸屏投票电脑的培训。非营利组织给了他们数百万美元来帮助支付所有这些费用。
But the thing they're really hoping will make this different than last time is that they're trying to get people to vote now in person or in the mail. Rick will tell any reporter who gets within two feet of him that he wants as many people as possible to vote before Election Day. 80% is his goal.
但他们真正希望会让这次与上次不同的是，他们正在努力让人们现在亲自或通过邮件投票。里克会告诉任何靠近他两英尺的记者，他希望尽可能多的人在选举日之前投票。80% 是他的目标。
So a couple of weeks ago, early voting began in Georgia. Rick and his team had been working nonstop through the weekends, right up till the midnight before the polls opened, to make sure the machines would work without a hitch, and the lines would move quickly. When I saw Rick, he was often harried, messy hair, hopping between meetings.
所以几周前，佐治亚州开始了提前投票。里克和他的团队整个周末都在不停地工作，直到投票开放前的午夜，以确保机器能正常工作，队伍能快速移动。当我看到里克时，他经常显得焦头烂额，头发凌乱，在会议之间跳来跳去。
On Monday morning, October 12, the first day of early voting, I went to the largest polling place in the county. It's actually the giant arena where the Atlanta Hawks play. The team offered it up after what happened during the primary. I wanted to see how things would go.
10 月 12 日周一早上，提前投票的第一天，我去了该县最大的投票点。它实际上是亚特兰大老鹰队比赛的巨大竞技场。球队在初选后发生了什么事之后提供了它。我想看看情况会怎样。
Hey, how's it going? I'm trying to meet up with the Fulton County elections director, who's inside. Gate 2?
嘿，怎么样？我正试图与富尔顿县选举主管会面，他在里面。2 号门？
When I get there around 8:00, hundreds of people were already lined up, and TV crews were camped out. I tracked down Rick near some closed concession stands.
我在 8 点左右到达那里时，数百人已经排起了长队，电视摄制组也在露营。我在一些关闭的特许摊位附近找到了里克。
Wow, you see how many people are out there?
哇，你看到外面有多少人了吗？
Yeah.
是的。
That's really like-- hold on.
那真的像是——等等。
Rick takes a call, talking through a black mask with "Vote" written on it in bold white print. He's more put together than usual-- clean shaven, wearing a dark blue suit. It's a big day. Then, an election worker comes up to him. People are trying to vote, but an error keeps popping up-- "Session ID invalid."
里克接了个电话，透过一个用粗体白色印着“投票”字样的黑色口罩说话。他比平时更整洁——刮过脸，穿着深蓝色西装。这是一个大日子。然后，一名选举工作人员走到他身边。人们正试图投票，但一个错误不断弹出——“会话 ID 无效”。
They aren't working? What, on all of them?
它们不工作吗？什么，它们全都不工作吗？
They have over 300 voting computers at the arena. Apparently, none of them are working. Rick hurries down some stairs, past empty seats, to the floor of the arena where the voting computers are set up, a jumbotron overhead. Lines fill the hallways of the arena.
竞技场里有超过 300 台投票电脑。显然，它们都不工作了。里克匆忙走下楼梯，经过空座位，来到竞技场的地板上，那里设置了投票电脑，头顶上有一个巨大的屏幕。队伍排满了竞技场的走廊。
Rick, is that you?
里克，那是你吗？
Uh-huh.
嗯哼。
Yeah, so the first two people that came down both did not make it through. And so that's when-- and then we stopped people from coming.
是的，所以进来的前两个人都没有通过。所以那就是什么时候——然后我们阻止了人们进来。
I've already got a call into Nadine as we speak.
我说话时已经给娜丁打了电话。
A Hawks employee comes up to Rick and is like, what are we supposed to tell the people in line?
一名老鹰队的员工走到里克身边，就像，我们应该告诉排队的人什么？
From what I understand, the lines are rapidly, rapidly growing.
据我所知，队伍正在迅速、迅速地增长。
We stopped processing across the building.
我们停止了整个大楼的处理。
OK.
好的。
Rick is on the phone basically this whole time. I've seen him in situations like this before. Everyone around him is wound up, and he sort of slows down.
里克基本上一直都在电话上。我以前在类似这样的情况下见过他。他周围的每个人都很紧张，而他却慢了下来。
I mean, we've tested all these poll pads so I just don't understand how this-- what the [BLEEP] is going on. [SIGHS]
我的意思是，我们测试了所有这些投票板，所以我根本不明白这——到底发生了什么事。[叹气]
He runs up the stairs, breathing hard because of his mask, looking for a county IT employee. Then the CEO of the Hawks, Steve Koonin, comes up to him. This is not the public relations win Koonin was hoping for when he offered up his team's arena.
他跑上楼梯，因为戴着口罩呼吸困难，在寻找一名县 IT 员工。然后老鹰队的首席执行官史蒂夫·库宁走过来找他。这不是库宁在他提供球队竞技场时所希望的公共关系胜利。
We should not have been put in this position one hour in, where I have to stand in front of the press and tell them why people can't vote.
我们不应该在开始一小时后就处于这种境地，我必须站在媒体面前告诉他们为什么人们不能投票。
Yeah, I know. Well, we'll get it. We'll get it squared away here. These two guys right now are resetting poll pads, so we're going to be able to get--
是的，我知道。嗯，我们会得到的。我们会在我们这里把它平方化。这两个家伙现在正在重置投票板，所以我们将能够得到——
Right, but they have to do 60 manually.
对，但他们必须手动做 60 个。
Yeah.
是的。
And that's not fast. And they don't seem to be-- I mean, that's a voter that is literally--
而且那并不快。而且它们看起来不像——我的意思是，那是一个字面上的选民——
Rick and the Fulton staff finally figure out a fix. They have to update a file and reset the iPads used to check people in. The lines start moving. People can vote.
里克和富尔顿的工作人员终于想出了一个修复方法。他们必须更新一个文件并重置用于检查人们身份的 iPad。队伍开始移动。人们可以投票了。
[CHEERING]
[欢呼]
It was a small win for Rick and the Fulton staff. Later, the Hawks CEO, Koonin, came up to Rick again. An hour made a big difference. Everyone's pumped up, except for Rick. Listen to this exchange. Koonin's beaming, and Rick is like, this was awful.
对于里克和富尔顿的工作人员来说，这是一个小小的胜利。后来，老鹰队的首席执行官库宁再次走到里克身边。一个小时带来了巨大的差异。每个人都很兴奋，除了里克。听听这段对话。库宁容光焕发，而里克却觉得这太糟糕了。
Well, I will say our recovery actually was faster than it felt.
嗯，我会说我们的恢复实际上比感觉到的要快。
All right, well, it just felt like a nightmare.
好吧，那感觉就像一场噩梦。
A nightmare?
一场噩梦？
I mean--
我的意思是——
Why don't we just go proactively talk to the press and knock it out and fix it?
为什么我们不主动去和媒体谈谈，解决它并修复它？
Yeah, that would be good.
是的，那会很好的。
I think it's the smartest thing we can do.
我认为这是我们能做的最聪明的事情。
Everyone ready? Everybody ready? All right, well, good morning. I'm Rob Pitts. I'm chairman of the Board of Commissioners of Fulton County.
每个人准备好了吗？每个人准备好了吗？好的，那么，早上好。我是罗布·皮茨。我是富尔顿县委员会主席。
Pitts tells the reporters and TV cameras how great things are going. Then Rick gets the job of explaining what went wrong.
皮茨告诉记者和电视摄像机事情进行得多么顺利。然后里克接过了解释出了什么问题的任务。
An issue I don't know the cause of it yet. There's something with the database on the poll pads that was here. So we apologize to all of the voters and to the Hawks and Mr. Koonin.
一个我不知道原因的问题。这里投票板上的数据库出了点问题。所以我们向所有选民以及老鹰队和库宁先生道歉。
Afterward, Rick walks to the floor of the arena and pauses, just for a moment. It's serene, watching the people quietly vote. Then he heads to his car. It's around noon, but he seems tired.
之后，里克走到竞技场的地板上并暂停，只是片刻。这很宁静，看着人们安静地投票。然后他朝他的车走去。大概是中午了，但他看起来很累。
I was feeling so comfortable, and I'm watching people coming in, streaming into the building. And I was like-- I was excited. I thought, oh, wow, this is going to be so good. And then that. What a morning. But I don't understand. I mean, some people are complaining that, wow, this is-- I heard somebody say we've got June all over again this morning at these early voting sites. And it's like, we got 32 sites open. In June, it was five.
我感觉很舒服，我看着人们进来，涌入大楼。我就——我很兴奋。我想，哦，哇，这会很棒的。然后那个。真是一个早晨。但我听不懂。我的意思是，有些人抱怨说，哇，这是——我听到有人说我们今天早上在这些提前投票点又经历了一次六月。就像，我们开了 32 个点。在六月，是五个。
There were snags in those first days. Lines did get long sometimes. But Rick felt like things were under control. But Tuesday night, I got an email from Rick's assistant with some scary news. One of the election staff tested positive for the virus, just like during the primary. I called Rick the next day. By then, even more people had tested positive.
在最初的几天里有困难。队伍有时确实排得很长。但里克觉得情况已得到控制。但周二晚上，我收到了里克助理发来的一封带有可怕消息的电子邮件。一名选举工作人员检测出病毒呈阳性，就像初选期间一样。我第二天给里克打了电话。到那时，甚至更多的人检测呈阳性。
I'm doing a press conference at 2:00. I don't know if you got it, but I've got 13 infections at the warehouse.
我 2 点要开新闻发布会。我不知道你是否收到了，但我有 13 个感染者在仓库里。
The warehouse is where the county keeps all the printers and voting computers. They've always been worried about the virus spreading there because it's so full of equipment, and it's hard to stay six feet apart. People do wear masks. And one manager even had a barrier in her office so that people couldn't get close. But she still got sick.
仓库是县里储存所有打印机和投票电脑的地方。他们一直担心病毒会在那里传播，因为它充满了设备，而且很难保持六英尺的距离。人们确实戴口罩。甚至一位经理在她的办公室里设了一个屏障，这样人们就无法靠近。但她还是生病了。
I just don't want anybody to die out of this or be one of those long haulers where they are just sick forever. Hopefully they'll get over it quick. But we've got a couple guys that are sick that are seniors. I don't know. [SIGHS] Kind of a-- I mean, this going to end up being a national story, probably, when you've got this many in an elections warehouse. This isn't like one or two. This is a full-blown outbreak.
我只是不希望任何人因为这个而死，或者成为那些永远生病的“长期携带者”之一。希望他们能很快好起来。但我们有几个生病的家伙是老年人。我不知道。[叹气]有点——我的意思是，当你有这么多在选举仓库里时，这最终会成为全国新闻，可能。这不像一两个。这是一个全面的爆发。
By Monday, two days later, the total was 23 cases. At least one person was in the hospital. All the workers at the warehouse were sent home, except for a few who hadn't tested positive.
周一，两天后，总数是 23 例。至少一个人在医院。仓库的所有工人都被送回家，除了几个没检测呈阳性的人。
I'm at the warehouse. I'll be here for a minute. Hold on for a second. I got a call coming through.
我在仓库里。我会在这里待一会儿。等一下。我有电话进来了。
I called Tim Cummings one night. He's the manager at the warehouse who you heard earlier.
我有一天晚上打电话给蒂姆·卡明斯。他就是你之前听到的仓库经理。
Are you worried about getting sick?
你担心生病吗？
Yeah, I been worried about getting sick since March. A lot of my crew scared, but we come in, we do what we gotta do. We're worried about making sure this election happens successfully. So we're doing everything we can to get it done.
是的，我从三月以来一直担心生病。我的很多船员都很害怕，但我们进来了，我们做我们必须做的事。我们担心确保这次选举成功进行。所以我们正在尽我们所能完成它。
What are you most worried about right now, in terms of pulling off the election?
你现在最担心的是什么，就完成选举而言？
Getting it all done in time. 'Cause right now, one of the reasons I stay so late is I'm like, if I can make everything that they need to do the L&A and program the machines--
及时完成所有工作。因为现在，我留得这么晚的原因之一是我就像，如果我能做他们需要做的所有事情来进行 L&A 并为机器编程——
He's talking about getting the voting computers all ready for testing and then delivered to polling places by Election Day.
他谈论的是让投票电脑为测试做好准备，然后在选举日之前送到投票点。
If I can get all of that prepared before something happens-- before I full out test positive or whatever, everything will be fine. 'Cause somebody else can step in at that point. My worry is not getting that complete. Hoping I can hold out till everybody else comes back, or somebody gets back.
如果我能在发生什么事之前准备好所有这些——在我完全测试呈阳性或其他任何事情之前，一切都会好起来的。因为到那时其他人可以介入。我的担心是没完成那个。希望我能撑到大家都回来，或者有人回来。
All over the country, people are freaking out about the election, worried about hacking, violence and intimidation, the supposed voter fraud President Trump keeps talking about. But none of that has been a big problem for Rick and the Fulton staff. Their problem is something bigger.
在全国各地，人们对选举感到疯狂，担心黑客、暴力和恐吓，以及特朗普总统一直谈论的所谓选民欺诈。但所有这些对于里克和富尔顿的工作人员来说都不是大问题。他们的问题是更重大的事情。
Yeah, the virus has been the disruption. I mean, I heard somebody yesterday say, oh, I've lived through the decades of the '60s, '70s, '80s, '90s, oughts and the teens, and now I've also lived through every month of 2020. You know, it's like-- it's almost like its own decade in itself. And yeah, I mean, this has been the weirdest year of my life.
是的，这种病毒一直是一种干扰。我的意思是，我昨天听到有人说，哦，我经历过 60 年代、70 年代、80 年代、90 年代、00 年代和 10 年代的几十年，现在我也经历了 2020 年的每一个月。你知道，就像——它本身就像自己的十年。而且是的，我的意思是，这是我一生中最奇怪的一年。
The county hired some outside help. Rick says the plan right now is just for everyone to work really long days.
该县雇佣了一些外部帮助。里克说目前的计划只是每个人工作很长时间。
Johnny Kauffman is a reporter with Atlanta's public radio station, WABE. His reporting at the Fulton County Elections Department is possible thanks to the Nieman Foundation for Journalism and the Abrams Foundation. As I'm recording this, the total number of election workers in Fulton County that have tested positive for COVID is 25. Two people are in the ICU. Some others have returned to work.
约翰尼·考夫曼是亚特兰大公共广播电台 WABE 的记者。他在富尔顿县选举部门的报道多亏了尼曼新闻基金会和艾布拉姆斯基金会。当我录制这个节目时，富尔顿县检测出新冠呈阳性的选举工作人员总数是 25 人。两人在重症监护室。一些其他人已经回到工作岗位。
[MUSIC - "UNREAL REALITY" BY THE KINKS]
[音乐 - 金克斯的“UNREAL REALITY”]
Our program was produced today by Robyn Semien and Susan Burton. The people who put our program together today include Bim Adewunmi, Ben Calhoun, Dana Chivvis, Sean Cole, Hilary Elkins, Noor Gill, Damien Grave, Michelle Harris, Chana Joffe-Walt, Seth Lind, Miki Meek, Lina Misitzis, Stowe Nelson, Katherine Rae Mondo, Lilly Sullivan, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, Julie Whitaker, and Diane Wu. Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman. Our senior editor is David Kestenbaum. Our executive editor is Emanuele Berry.
我们的节目今天由罗宾·塞米恩和苏珊·伯顿制作。今天一起制作我们节目的人包括比姆·阿德武米、本·卡尔霍恩、达纳·奇维斯、肖恩·科尔、希拉里·埃尔金斯、努尔·吉尔、达米安·格雷夫、米歇尔·哈里斯、查纳·乔夫-沃尔特、塞思·林德、米基·米克、莉娜·米西齐斯、斯托·尼尔森、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多、莉莉·沙利文、克里斯托弗·斯韦塔拉、马特·蒂尔尼、朱莉·惠特克和黛安·吴。我们的执行编辑是莎拉·阿卜杜拉赫曼。我们的资深编辑是大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆。我们的执行编辑是伊曼纽尔·贝里。
Special thanks to Chris Haxel, Emma Hurt, Mate Halmos, Mikaela Robertson, Anna Luhrmann, John Carey, Geneva Solomon and Redstone Firearms, Laurie Abraham, and Katherine Wells.
特别感谢克里斯·哈克塞尔、艾玛·赫特、马特·哈尔莫斯、米凯拉·罗伯逊、安娜·卢尔曼、约翰·凯里、日内瓦·所罗门和红石枪支、劳里·亚伯拉罕和凯瑟琳·威尔斯。
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. He was invited to a party this week. He dressed for Halloween as Michael J. Fox in Teen Wolf. When he got there, he realized it was a fundraising gala, black tie.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由 PRX（公共广播交易所）分发给公共广播电台。像往常一样，感谢我们节目的联合创始人托雷·马拉蒂亚先生。他本周受邀参加了一个派对。他扮成《少年狼》中的迈克尔·J·福克斯参加万圣节。当他到那儿时，他意识到这是一个筹款晚会，黑色领带。
I'm there in cut-off sweatpants and a hoodie, wearing a mask.
我穿着剪短的运动裤和连帽衫，戴着口罩在那里。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。
[MUSIC - "UNREAL REALITY" BY THE KINKS]
[音乐 - 金克斯的“UNREAL REALITY”]